Since 1937, the Tomb of
the Unknowns has famously never once been
left unattended with there always being at
least one guard present to keep vigil.
The highly coveted position of Tomb Sentinel
is only meted out to truly exceptional soldiers,
all of whom must prove their dedication and
mettle through a series of grueling and somewhat
unusual tests.
For starters, to even be considered for the
position of Sentinel, a given soldier must
be a member of the 3rd U.S. Infantry Regiment,
who are colloquially and rather aptly known
as the “Old Guard” due to being the oldest
currently serving unit in the US military,
with the unit’s history stretching all the
way back to 1784.
Because the Old Guard is tasked with the solemn
duty of handling some of the most sensitive
and delicate obligations the Army has to attend
to, such as welcoming foreign dignitaries
to the country and escorting the coffins of
fallen soldiers during military funerals,
it invariably only recruits the best and brightest
soldiers it can find.
Along with possessing a flawless record, any
soldier hoping to be recruited by the Old
Guard must be in excellent physical condition,
be in the top percentile of military aptitude
tests and possess a number of “intangible
traits” the military doesn’t bother to
define in any source we could find.
On top of this, soldiers must also have “proportionate
weight and build” to their height, limiting
the post to only the very finest physical
specimens the Army has to offer.
This is because the members of the Old Guard
in many of their ceremonial duties are supposed
to represent the entire army to the outside
world.
After becoming a member of the Old Guard,
a soldier can, if they so choose, apply to
be a Tomb Sentinel via the Sergeant of the
Guard by simply knocking on the door to his
or her office and stating interest.
While this is rather simple, to be considered
and score an interview, a soldier has to have
distinguished themselves from the rest of
the Old Guard with their dedication and conduct,
as well as possess the aforementioned unmistakably
“soldierly appearance”, the exact meaning
of which isn’t abundantly clear.
After this the soldier will then be given
a two week trial period where they will be
given basic instruction on the history of
the Tomb and Arlington National Cemetery (both
of which are extremely interesting, see: Who
is Buried in the Tomb of the Unknown Soldier?
and The Fascinating Origin of Arlington National
Cemetery).
They are also tutored in the expectations
placed upon Sentinels and their general duties
and given a crash course in how to maintain
their uniform (which is much harder than you
might think as we’ll get to in a moment).
At the end of the trial, the soldier will
be given a test on each one of these points
which they’re expected to pass with only
a 5% margin of error.
If they fail any test, they will no longer
be considered for guard duty.
Any soldier able to pass this trial period
will then be handed over to a seasoned Tomb
Sentinel for a year of additional training.
Under the tutelage of the experienced Sentinel
the soldier is expected to, among other things,
learn 17 pages of additional detailed history
about the Tomb and cemetery which they are
expected to recite back on command perfectly
and put in written form including all relevant
punctuation, with only a few mistakes allowed.
Furthermore, trainee Tomb Guards aren’t
allowed to laugh or even smile while they’re
on duty (even in the guard house) and are
expected to hold themselves in the most respectful
manner possible at all times due to the close
proximity of said Tomb Guards’ quarters
to the Tomb itself.
According to an interview Sentinel Andrew
Selga gave to the Washington Post, during
their training period, trainees are also told
that they’re not allowed to acknowledge
the existence of furniture while on duty,
even if that means walking straight through
a chair.
This is of course used as a way to get trainees
used to ignoring pain of fatigue, as well
as outside influences, while remaining stoic
in most every situation.
Then you have uniforms.
The basic uniform of a Tomb Sentinel consists
of a heavy wool uniform that weighs in excess
of 10 pounds on its own, an M14 rifle outfitted
with a custom stock, heavy boots with metal
inserts to assist in making that signature
“click” sound everyone loves so much and
a host of smaller adornments like belts, holsters
and a pair of sunglasses to help shield a
guard’s eyes from glare.
It’s noted that trainee guards will sometimes
spend in excess of 10-12 hours per day just
cleaning and preparing their uniform to get
it to the exacting standards of their superiors
who themselves will spend about 6-8 hours
cleaning and pressing their own uniforms,
despite their extensive experience in the
task.
As part of this preparation, the badges, buttons
and medals on the uniform must also be accurately
placed to within “1/64th of an inch”.
The uniform standards for the Tomb Guard are
so legendarily strict that to pass the test
to become a fully fledged member of the unit,
trainees will be asked to present themselves
in uniform whereupon they are marked on 100
individual points by a superior.
Prospective guards are allowed only two minor
infractions during this test (so must achieve
98% or greater).
In keeping with the ideal that the Tomb Guards
must always strive to be better, nobody has
ever been given a perfect score.
For the most part, the uniform of Tomb guards
remains pretty much unchanged throughout the
year, with the only real changes occurring
in winter, when the guards are permitted to
wear seasonal appropriate hats and gloves
if they so choose.
For anyone curious about what would happen
in the very likely event a guard turned up
for his or her shift and felt that it was
too cold or hot for the uniform, according
to the aforementioned Sentinel Andrew Selga
they’d simply be told to “suck it up”.
Not that many guards would complain; in fact,
most guards with this duty consider it an
honor to be tasked with guarding the tomb
during the most extreme bouts of weather,
which probably explains why the tomb has remained
under guard during extreme heat, snow, hail,
rain and the occasional hurricane.
In the most extreme weather, such as during
the relatively recent Hurricane Sandy, they
are allowed to stand watch in a small enclosure
known as “the box”, made of cloth with
an open front, but for no more than two hour
intervals before resuming their march.
In that particular storm, one Sgt. Shane Vincent
volunteered to take an entire 24 hour shift,
though occasionally his fellow guards joined
him for support.
If and only if a trainee is considered ready,
they will be given the honor of conducting
a “walk”, which basically entails what
a fully fledged guard would do, only it is
conducted at night, away from the prying eyes
of the public and under strict supervision.
In accordance with tradition, a walk consists
of the following:
While on duty the sentinel crosses a 63-foot
rubber surfaced walkway in exactly 21 steps.
He then faces the Tomb for 21 seconds, turns
again, and pauses an additional 21 seconds
before retracing his steps.
The cadence of the march and placement of
feet is strictly graded and the number 21
is of paramount important to a successful
walk as it is symbolic of a “21 gun salute”.
(See: Why Do They Use 21 Guns in the 21 Gun
Salute?)
After a walk duty is completed, the guard
will then be relieved of his or her position
with an elaborate changing of the guard ceremony,
which occurs every one hour in the winter
and every half hour in the summer and proceeds
as follows:
a relief commander salutes the tomb and announces
the change.
‘Ladies and gentlemen, may I have your attention
please.
I am (name and rank) of the 3rd Infantry Regiment,
United States Army, commander of the relief,
Tomb of the Unknown Soldier.
The ceremony you are about to witness, is
the Changing of the Guard.
In keeping with the dignity of this ceremony,
it is requested that everyone remain silent,
and standing.
Thank you.’
He inspects the oncoming Soldier and his weapon
(depending on whether he wears cold-weather
gloves, which prohibit a complete weapon inspection),
then he and the new Soldier meet the retiring
sentinel in front of the tomb and all three
salute the unknowns.
‘Pass on your orders,’ the relief commander,
who is the only Soldier entitled to wear rank
insignia, directs the relieved sentinel, according
to the tomb’s standard operating procedures.
The relieved sentinel then tells his replacement:
‘Post and orders remain as directed.’
‘Orders acknowledged,’ the new sentinel
replies before beginning his patrol.
This ceremony is mostly for show, and only
really occurs during the cemetery’s open
hours.
However, just because there’s nobody around
at night when the cemetery is closed doesn’t
mean the theatrics stop.
Long after the gates to Arlington close, even
in the wee hours of the morning, guards and
sentinels never stop watching over the tomb
and continue their walking along that 63 feet
of rubber with incredible precision.
In accordance with tradition, nobody who guards
the tomb wears anything that would denote
rank, so that nobody outranks the unknowns.
However, after a year of constant drills and
training and if they’re able to pass a series
of tests that demand nothing short of perfection,
a trainee will be promoted to tomb guard and
given a Tomb Guard Identification Badge.
After receiving this badge, if they have served
in this capacity for nine months without being
removed from the post for some infraction,
they are allowed to wear it for the rest of
their military career and officially gain
the title of “Sentinel” rather than just
“Guard”; although if they ever stop achieving
the rigorous standards set for one of these
guards, they may be removed from this duty.
The testing in this way never stops, nor does
their training both for this ceremonial duty
and keeping up with actual combat and tactical
training, which generally takes place in their
off time; you see, the Old Guard isn’t just
in charge of these ceremonial posts, but also
charged with protecting Washington D.C. and
being the official escort to the President.
Though Sentinels and guards are almost entirely
silent during walks, they are permitted to
momentarily abstain from their duties to confront
members of the public they believe are acting
in a disrespectful manner or anyone who attempts
to approach the tomb.
However, as one guard noted, people dropping
water bottles or the like that roll towards
the tomb (with the person often scrambling
to grab it and return behind the line) is
a regular occurrence and if seemingly accidental
the guard is likely to ignore it.